neben massen pflicht können auch
abstandsregeln und isolationen eltern
und kinder belasten wie sehr möchte ich
mit facharzt für kinder und
jugendmedizin dr hermann josef kahl
besprechen drk welche auswirkung hat der
lock down auf unsere kinder der lok
gehört natürlich auch kinder je nach
alter eine unterschiedliche auswirkungen
viele kinder die ganz jung sind verstehe
überhaupt nicht worum es geht und die
älteren kinder die so im schulalter oder
vielleicht sogar auf dem gymnasium sind
die spüren schon dass hier ein virus
existiert diese und der sie unter
umständen krank machen kann
ja wir sind dann langfristige folgen
vermeidbar naja wenn die eltern
altersgemäß mit den kindern über diese
geschichte sprechen dann wird man bei
den kindern voreiligen einsatz sollten
dass ich keine angst haben und das ist
auch ganz wichtig kinder dürfen nicht
angst ängstlich werden nicht traurig
werden sie müssen wissen dass mit diesen
maßnahmen eine schutzfunktion errichtet
wird und dass die eltern vor allen
dingen hinter ihnen stehen und sie
beschützen das muss immer wieder in
gesprächen den kinder verlegt werden
mein neffe sieben jahre der es relativ
entspannt aber wie erklärt man
hygienemaßnahmen und masken ohne angst
zu vermitteln beziehungsweise auszulösen
also ich stelle immer wieder fest dass
kinder auch kleine kinder mit der masse
überhaupt kein problem haben
offensichtlich gibt es die signale der
eltern die die kinder schon muss es ja
früher aufnehmen die signale sind eben
die gleichen die feuerung die entdecken
überhaupt keinen unterschied wer denkt
bei den eltern keine panik werden von
denen beruhigt das wird einfach als
selbstverständlich gegeben vor allem
über den kleinen und da stellt man bei
den kleinen finger neigend überhaupt
keine angst ist ja wo die angst beginnt
immer dann wenn die eltern wenn die
kinder nicht altersgerecht über diese
maßnahme informiert werden wenn irgendwo
den ln unsicherheiten besteht oder bei
den erziehern oder lehrern dann kann
dass sich bei kindern übertragen oder
dann kann das natürlich ein ängste bei
den kindern hervorrufen und deswegen
mein appell immer diese dinge mit dem
geld mit den kindern zu erklären dass
sie aufgrund ihres kognitiven
entwicklungsstand es in der lage sind
das zu erkennen und das zu begreifen und
dazu einigen angstfrei zu begreifen man
will
die angst zu viel also was sind die
kennzeichen die wir als erwachsene lesen
müssen
der kleine kinder fangen ganz klar an zu
weinen und zeigen ihre angst mit mit
einem weinen während etwas größere
kinder natürlich schon angst verein
anfangen oder umständen dinge zu zeigen
wie schlaflosigkeit oder mehr
anhänglichkeit und sind nicht mehr so
sicher in denen die wie es sie früher
gewesen sind dass während ein anzeichen
von den eltern sagen müsste jetzt
aufpassen bitte mit den kindern reden
und so reden wie es ihren reifegrad
entspricht
und dann immer wieder zeigen dass die
eltern dahinter stehen und ihnen helfen
und sie beschützen und dann geht das
auch gut mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren